LAURENCE MORONEY: Welcome
to the Googleplex.
Today we're going to be
talking with Alan Huang.
He's here from the
Android TV team
that brings Android
into your living room
and allows you as an
application developer
to reach people in
their living room.
Android TV is one
of these products
that I think we all know
a little bit about it,
but maybe we don't know
exactly what it is,
so could you tell us
exactly what is Android TV?
ALLEN HUANG: What
we're really doing
with Android TV is we're
bringing Android, this OS that
is widely popular
and people are super
familiar with because they're
using it on a day-to-day basis
all the time, and bring that
experience to the living room
and across a variety of
devices on actual smart TVs
that you're buying, you know,
60 inch televisions, as well as
boxes that you connect
to your television,
whether that's a box that's
coming from whoever's
giving you your cable television
or a box you're connecting
to stream different content.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
Now, one of my favorite features
in Android is Google Now.
That gives me like
personalized recommendations.
And one of my problems
with TV at the moment
is that there's so many
different, either channels
on cable or different
sources of on demand video
and trying to find what I want
to watch is really difficult.
Is there some kind
of recommendation
engine that thinks about
what I like to watch
and maybe bubbles that
to the top in Android TV?
ALLEN HUANG: One of
our big focus areas
when we were thinking about
what Android TV should be was,
we centered around
this concept of, when
you get home after a long day at
work, your IQ almost goes down,
right?
You're sitting in
front of the TV.
The last thing you
want to think about
is, OK, what am
I going to watch?
And look through
a ton of listings
and try to just figure
all of that out.
And so what we've done
is, the centerpiece
of the home screen on Android
TV is this recommendation show.
And what we're doing
there is combining
a few pieces of information.
We're taking all of the stuff
that the apps that you have,
the TV providers that you have,
taking all of that information
and then mixing it
together to showcase, OK,
what are the things that we
think you'll want to watch.
The apps provide
these recommendations.
And then we sort of
rank based on what apps
you've been using in the past.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
Cool.
Now, I understand that
you were down in Las Vegas
at CES, launching some Android
TV stuff quite recently.
And we all know how
crazy CES can be.
But what happened?
What did you do?
What did you launch?
What was going on?
ALLEN HUANG: For Android TV,
the main reason we were there
was helping support our
partners as they were launching
the first really
Android TV devices that
are going to be outside of
our own Nexus player device.
And so, what we saw
was Sony announcing
that their entire Bravia 2K
and 4K TVs in this coming 2015
line-- they're all going
to be running Android TVs.
So Sharp also announced
that their 4K televisions
would be running Android TV.
And then Razer is working
on a gaming console that's
running on Android
TV and features
a wide variety of games.
And they actually
won the best of CES
in the gaming category, as well
as the People's Choice Award.
And we have these
partners developing
these incredible devices
on the Android TV platform.
For me, it was really
exciting to see.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Yeah, that sounds cool.
Now, you mentioned
the gaming console.
Is that out yet or
is that coming soon?
ALLEN HUANG: Razer is
working hard in order
and we're getting to
that point where that
should be coming very soon.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Now my understanding
is because that runs Android
TV, it has a version of the Play
Store so then anybody
who can build a game
and put it into
the Play Store now
has a console that
they can build for.
ALLEN HUANG: Yeah, the
experience for a developer
is that Play Store works much
the same way that you would
expect on a phone or a tablet.
You're using the same Play
Store developer console.
You're creating
just Android apps,
with a different interface,
with a different UI.
But really it's the
same Android API.
It's the same Android
development model.
And it's just going to
transfer from device to device.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK, so if I'm
an existing Android developer,
building for phones and maybe
building for tablets, then if I
want to reach the
form factor of the TV,
I'm pretty much
using the same APIs?
ALLEN HUANG: Yeah absolutely.
I mean, Android TV
is on Lollipop, just
like every other device.
And all of the
APIs that you know
and love that you're
using already,
they're just going
to work, right?
Like one of the big
differences with Android TV,
compared with the
other efforts, is
that we're on the same cycle
as phone, as tablet, as ware,
as auto, and I think we talk
about how if the Android TV
team doesn't finish the
work that we need to finish,
we're going to delay everything.
All of Android is--
LAURENCE MORONEY: No pressure.
ALLEN HUANG: Yeah,
no, no pressure.
We're a core part there.
And so with that comes
just tons of benefits.
It makes a lot of
sense for developers.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool, cool.
So now there must
be some differences
though when building for
the Leanback form factor,
the TV as opposed to the small
device that's in your hand.
Like what kind of challenges
do you see developers facing
and what have you
done to help them?
ALLEN HUANG: One you
don't have a touch screen.
Maybe one day, our partners are
going to build a touch screen
TV and that'll be really cool.
But for the most
part, these TVs are
things that are you're
interacting with a D-pad.
So left, right, up,
down, center click.
You'll have the back
and home that you
have on every Android device.
And that's the basic interaction
model, and it's very simple.
It matches that sort
of whole mentality of,
I'm in front of my living room.
I'm not really
thinking that hard.
I don't want a computing device,
I want an entertainment device.
The other thing beyond
sort of the interaction
is that you are sitting 10
feet away from this screen.
And you know the
font sizes need to be
the size that they need to be.
All the images that are on
screen need to be bigger,
and you need to think about
them being more cinematic.
And people have a
certain expectation of,
on television things being
sort of moving, and cinematic,
and it being that sort
of engaging experience.
And so, that's all
things that we're
thinking very carefully about
as we're developing Android TV.
As far as what we've
done for developers,
we've tried to make this
really easy for them.
And so we have this model
of having support libraries
that we've published
and made available
along with the Android SDK to
make it really easy for people
to just have that sort of
UI and interaction model.
So these support libraries
provide almost sort
of templates that people could
plug in their information,
take their Android tablet
app, and plug that in and have
this rich, engaging, immersive
UI, and have it displayed,
and have all the transitions
and animations that I
was talking about.
From there, a developer can
take that and run with it
and publish it to Play
Store almost immediately.
Or they can do lots of
things like customize it,
sort of make it their
brand, take those and then
just build upon that.
And then we also have developers
that will start totally
from scratch.
They're like, oh hey, yeah,
this support library is great,
but I'd rather just
create a whole experience.
And they're just
developing an Android app.
LAURENCE MORONEY: That's
kind of mind blowing
when you think about it.
That when, in the past if you're
building for a TV set-top box
or for a console, it was an
entirely different world.
What you're bringing now
is the same world into it.
And yes, there are some
differences, of course,
but you're trying to mitigate
the difficulties that might
come from those differences.
Cool.
What about like any
kind of scenarios
for interesting types of apps?
ALLEN HUANG: I'm really
excited about what's to come,
what developers are going to do.
For phones and tablets, people
who built the operating system
never imagined, sort of the
possibilities of what people
would go and create
and have become just
absurdly popular-- ways for you
to get picked up from anywhere
and be able to take
you to any other place.
Other really amazing
stuff that I've seen
is, so Dish just
announced their Sling app
that you can have physical this
subscription experience where
you're getting a core
set of channels, getting,
for me, like the ESPN,
all of that is amazing.
I've seen really fun apps.
E24 is a good example,
where they've made it
so that you can actually
order food from your TV screen
and order it and have it
delivered to your home.
It sort of runs the gamut.
Our team's goal is to
provide the tools for people
to build whatever they
can imagine and then see
where it goes from there.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I'm
waiting for the 3D
printer that can print a pizza.
And order that through my TV.
ALLEN HUANG: Yeah,
immediate delivery.
LAURENCE MORONEY: That
would be crazy So thinking
of like developers, and we're
saying that like the experience
is very familiar.
As an Android developer, do you
have any words like for anybody
who wants to get started today?
Maybe they're not an
Android developer already
or maybe they've been
building for phones.
What advice would you give to
folks who want to get started?
ALLEN HUANG: Absolutely take
a look at our support library.
The feedback we get from a lot
of developers is like, oh man,
that was a lot easier
I thought it would be.
And just to get
started that way,
messing around
and experimenting,
and trying a few things
out, especially when
we've provided some
of the basic templates
so that you don't have
to worry about that.
I think it goes a long way.
Being quite honest,
there are lots
of apps that aren't very
good, but at the very least,
you're developing out the
skills, the experience,
and then it's like sort of an
iterative process, I think.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And we
are really only at day zero.
Right?
There's great stuff
still to come.
And try, if you're going
to fail, try again.
If you're going to fail,
try again and just keep
getting better incrementally.
I mean for developers.
So actually one question
that I had, I was thinking,
because I've played a
little bit with development,
but I have like the hardware.
I mean, is there like an
emulator or something like that
so if people don't
have the hardware,
that they can see what things
would look like on a TV?
ALLEN HUANG: So as
part of Android Studio,
and all those tools, we have the
emulator available for Android
TV, alongside all about
emulators that you have,
so you can see that experience.
We had the ADT-1 give
away and hopefully
many of the early developers
got their hands on one
and were able to
start development
using this device that we
internally know and love
because we used it
for quite awhile just
to get people started.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So we've had a lot
of success in the living
room with Chromecast,
which is a fabulous product.
But how does that fit
in with Android TV,
in particular from a
developer perspective?
What should developers
be thinking about?
ALLEN HUANG: Cast has been
incredibly successful in sort
of introducing this new
model for how people interact
with their living room.
Tying back to what I said
about the living room being
this really simple space,
where people aren't looking
for computing devices, being
able to take something and so
easily throw it
onto your screen,
it's just very
intuitive for people.
LAURENCE MORONEY: It's magical.
ALLEN HUANG: Yeah, exactly.
It is.
I mean, I've heard
people say that.
It's like, oh, my god,
how did that happen?
And it's something
we want to continue.
I think that
interaction model, we
baked Google Cast as a
core part of Android TV.
So everything that works
with the Chromecast,
you're able to take that and
then cast, pick up your phone
and then cast it to
any Android TV device.
Then from a developer
perspective,
you have these two
models where you're
developing this
cast-integrated experience,
as well as this Android
TV app, and developers
are going to ask, well,
that seems like there's
a lot of stuff going on.
One of the key
things is that you
want to be able to interact
with your service, your app,
in a variety of different ways.
You have this first
screen app, this
on phones, and for
similar reasons why
you want to have a
tablet experience too,
that's why you'd want
to have a TV experience.
So if you're just
streaming content,
casting make a lot of sense.
And having that experience
gets you the ability
to get your content on all the
Chromecast devices, as well
as all the Android TV devices.
But then beyond
that, if you want
to have suggestions on
screen or recommendations
or integration into search,
or just even like auto
playing to the
next video or being
able to show multiple
videocasts at once,
I think that's where you have
this Android TV native app
experience.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
But as a developer,
if I've invested
in the skills and building
for cast, they're not wasted.
ALLEN HUANG: Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I can continue
building for Android TV.
I could just extend
my skills set.
ALLEN HUANG: Yeah.
Yeah.
Totally.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
ALLEN HUANG: I'm so
excited to see what
they're going to come up with.
And you know, personally,
I joined this team
about a year ago and the living
room is an exciting space.
I think it's right
before-- I mean,
we are already
seeing lots and lots
of changes in this
environment and ecosystem.
More and more people are
just streaming content.
And--
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cord-cutting
is becoming commonplace, right?
ALLEN HUANG: Yeah, absolutely.
And there's a meme
that people are just
moving all their time to tablets
and to phones and to computers.
At least for me, I still
watch like multiple hours
of television every day.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Absolutely, me too.
ALLEN HUANG: For me, this is
almost embarrassing to say,
I fall asleep to the
television quite often.
I think there's room for
so much progress in how
we watch television.
But just keeping in
mind like, hey, this
is about making it
simple and easy.
And for me, that's a
really fun challenge.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool, cool.
Well, thanks, Allen.
And this has been a really
fun chat that we've had.
And everybody,
thanks for watching
this episode of "Coffee with
a Googler" with Allen Huang.
We spoke about Android TV.
We learned about
all the great ways
we can get started with
developing for Android TV,
using our existing
Android skills.
We have some links after
the end of the video
and they'll be in the
description below.
And again, thank you so
much, Allen, for coming.
ALLEN HUANG: Yeah,
cool Thank you.